and still undefeated the problem
[Applause]
jake paul now has another boxing win
under his belt after battling tyron
woodley was that tougher than you
expected it to be
cleveland what's good
on sunday the youtube star faced off
against the former ufc champion but
things didn't heat up until round three
of the match when jake hit tyron with
this uppercut left-hand combination plus
a body shot and left hook
[Applause]
and in round four tension continued
rising with tyron coming back at jake
with the most significant blow of the
fight causing jake to almost wobble
outside of the ring
but it was jake's performance in round
seven that guaranteed his final score
winning by a split decision
[Applause]
the judges called jake as the winner and
shortly after tyron says the fact that
one of the judges only gave him two
rounds was laughable he even suggested a
rematch me and jack need to run that
back so you want an immediate rematch is
that of interest off the top off the top
i want to answer rematch if you get the
tattoo i love jake paul let's run it
back
let's go
deal make the bet
get the tattoo get the tattoo we'll run
it back but this bet actually first
started in july when jake and tyron
confirmed to et that the original
agreement was for the loser of the match
to get the winner's name tattooed if you
lose will you actually get i love jake
paul tattooed on your body uh i'm not
gonna lose so i'm not really worried
about it it's more for him if you want
to tattoo a legend on his body then have
it i mean we shook on it so when he
loses you know we'll see if he's a man
of his word
he's supposed to post it on his
instagram feed so i i guess i guess
we'll see that you know the stakes have
increased and while we wait for a
rematch and a possible new tattoo the
youtube star still remains undefeated a
topic he opened up to et about in july
i've sparred hundreds of hours now
and have barely lost a round in sparring
so you know how how am i uh how am i
going to lose this fight and that's i
think really where my my confidence
comes from is the level of competition
i'm going against
in sparring and really pushing myself
and
the the haters fuel me you know they
have my whole entire career everyone's
doubted me i've been a massive underdog
the whole entire time people tell me i
can't do things and all it's done is
driven me
and gave me so much motivation
[Music]